[Music]
do you guys like going to
public bathrooms and peeing not that i
like it
my personal joy okay i think
about the question my favorite past time
well nowadays not as much
true i guess do you guys feel
uncomfortable
absolutely not really no i feel like i'm
at home i'm pretty comfortable
some people are like a lot more
comfortable than i am because i can't
poop in public
i'm not something i cannot do i'm a
public mover for sure
i'm gonna get over that real quick
though into that i got my baby
wipes in the fanny pack you know my life
i had to get over it
i think i it's harder for me to
understand
that struggle to not be able to poop
when you really have to poop
you don't get shy and other people walk
into them when i was 14 like they're in
the stall next to you and your poop just
kind of gets like
no well i did shine well the whole thing
is like the sound right you just don't
want like to make sound so sometimes i
will just
be waiting for the other person to leave
depends it all depends
and the sanitation levels of like the
public restroom or something that you
know
right oh god i can actually
[Laughter]
we're talking about like comfort level
right because there's also a discomfort
to needing the [ __ ] or take a piss you
know so if you're in a public space
you're just measuring which discomfort
you're down the part that i'm saying
that i'm like if i have to go i'm gonna
go
if i need a [ __ ] i'm gonna [ __ ] on the
floor bruh porta
i almost [ __ ] in your bush i'm on also a
porn category
um legit
like i cannot stand porta-potties oh
yeah i don't think anyone does go back
where's your breath i don't think
anyone's like you know what it's not
that bad
bathroom at home or a porta potty going
to the portal no
because they have some fancy ass ones
they have like a full-on the star tours
ones
yeah yeah they definitely have those
because yeah star
yeah it's all right those festival ones
where it's like a whole ass
box yeah you could sleep in there and
[ __ ]
yeah because like those massive ones
yeah
yeah i guess the fancy but i'm talking
about the blue the blue boys but
thinking about my younger self
in school like in high school middle
school i remember
being super shy to even pee like i
didn't want anyone to hear my p
sounds so now i can take a privacy thing
right yeah
you know in japan it plays the music
yeah
yeah i need music in the background
[Laughter]
you know one thing i hate about myself
that i do this [ __ ] to myself all the
[ __ ] time is you know when you go to
those public bathrooms that it's just
like
it's the toilet but then it's just a
hole and it's a [ __ ] abyss
they always go don't [ __ ] look at the
other [ __ ] and i always tell myself
don't talk about porta potties
like don't look at it don't [ __ ] look
at it and then i go i look at i'm like
oh [ __ ]
no don't no don't you gotta measure
which one's worse you know what i mean
if there's multiple porter parts you
gotta see which one has the lowest level
check no that's too much torture you
don't not
just the poop hole but you don't check
which one maybe is like the cleanest
porta potty the only thing i'm looking
at like around there but i don't
well that's why you you go to each one
and you kind of push it to see which
one's the lightest
what you know what he's inside
are you [ __ ] kidding me it was i was
gagging so hard right now i kind of
i need a good gag right now and it's not
coming out all right we'll move away
from port-a-potties yeah
let's go let's go back to public
bathrooms
all right let's go back to public
bathrooms uh dude when you guys use
public bathrooms you guys ever like
check your surroundings within that
public bath well yeah i mean like
in terms of just just irregularity yeah
like sure
you gotta watch out for glory holes dude
glory hole as well
i was able to have that in your mind i
was able to see the next stall
through the toilet paper holder that's
weird because okay the holder was
basically
it was empty like it was just rolls
right so we were sharing the same rules
and as i was pulling i was like what the
[ __ ]
and i can see the other dude pulling two
at the same time and i'm laying on you
oh my god it's like a lady in the tree
who's gonna get the last it was at the
las vegas airport it was [ __ ] weird
oh dude you know what else i've noticed
if the floor is
super shiny like it's actually actually
reflective you can see you can make out
what's underneath the stall
wow what the [ __ ] you could see them
they're on their phone like this and you
can see the reflection
yeah on the floor you can see the
reflection that's important wow
wait oh well
wait well a uh a girl
was using a restroom at her she calls it
a local acai bowl
shop so i guess there was a glory hole
there and a dick came out
not a glory hole a snake she found a
a mirror that was placed in a very
interesting
way and so now mirrors and bathrooms are
usually
is it like those shoe mirrors remember
those oh yeah what is that what is that
you don't remember this they take a shoe
it's kind of slanted yeah it's on the
floor and it's oh yeah a shoe store this
is for you
we're we're getting closer with that so
this this mirror that's a little place
below the height of like like an upskirt
position
it's like so if you're sitting like can
i oh yeah we can totally see this all
right so if i'm sitting here and i'm on
the toilet
it's like wow this height why then being
this height when you're when you're
trying to wash your hands why
wait right there all right so i have a
video this girl does a tic toc wait is
it a handicap
like and yeah i guess we got to see it
so no idea yeah let's take a look at
this
let me know what you guys that is a
weird place to have a mirror
here's the tick tock oh [ __ ] i'm an
idiot wait
that was the mirror there's a door
there's an entry light
i'm like where's the [ __ ] mirror it
looks like a window there we go
oh i love this [ __ ] this series
she sat down to give you an idea you
need to touch it
and she's like he does the mirror trick
it doesn't
wait for it right there yes so two-way
mirror it does this so there's a gap
between your finger and your reflection
and then if it if it is a two-way mirror
no
if it's a normal mirror there's that
there's a gap so did she punch through
it
well she didn't do that this is where
this tick tock ends so then she punched
through it i would have
kicked it i would have [ __ ] got
something and be like [ __ ] your beer
you're gonna [ __ ] inside of it no and
then film it take it to the cops
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you're going to jail
right yeah wow that's interesting that's
violent that [ __ ] pissed me off right
now yeah seeing that like made my blood
boil
now now that i know the the trick can i
see the video one more time
yeah yeah oh wait i'm playing
i've never checked before oh actually
why is there a mirror there dude it's
like perfect for the seat
pull the [ __ ] off girl you were right
there she tried
not hard enough that's what i'm saying i
was kicked in that [ __ ] mirror
all right so do you think they're
recording or like just
peeping are there people watching right
is there a camera on the other side it's
not a camera it's just people just there
can you imagine
that someone opened up acai bowl
thinking girls love acai
you know what i mean young girls they
targeted a demographic
yeah i hate it you're not gonna open up
a denture shop and do this
unless you like old ladies right right
right you're doing a shop
that's going to have a lot of young
girls girls yeah acai
yeah healthier healthy girls
we don't have mirrors yes but jumbie has
a lot of young people that likes to come
right or like like why are you attaching
the june being there
why are you talking about jupiter take
it back let's rewind
um take a sip take a step take a second
take things too seriously but
no i actually so i do some weird [ __ ] in
public bathroom sometimes so now i have
to freaking find out
what the hell is going on what are you
doing yeah like i jack off in public
bathroom don't you
for example like something i do because
once again i'm very uh
religious about baby wipes sometimes i
won't have any on me
so i will literally with my pants still
down
waddle over to the freaking sink get
paper towel wet it
go back and you know i mean so i will do
all that business
i've actually got a show watching you
will go back and forth right
and it's like it's like a [ __ ]
pac-man
no and then sometimes the guy behinds
like hey look at this one
hey she's back she's back
did she report what store it was and all
that oh yeah so
she i don't know if she reported this
this thing to the police or anything
but she made it take talk of it it went
viral
and then it caught the attention of
another tick tock user who was
i guess from the same area and she was
like i go to that samusai bowl place
so she made a tick tock and she did
yes she did oh my god oh my god yes part
two
[Music]
[ __ ] yes so this is the the second girl
take the screwdriver yeah
does the same little check and
what's on the other side nothing
[Music]
oh good oh good no no no no
it could be inside of the [ __ ] mirror
yeah
maybe it's just a shitty mirror so now
it's just so
apparently there's no hole in the wall
where there could be a camera or a
peeper
uh it's just so that finger trick is
fake so
i read up on this so i went on wikihow
and basically the way the mirrors are
it's actually not a foolproof way to
test it
so depending on the quality of mirror
and also the position of lighting and
everything so there's a lot of
physics involved here that test only
works if
a certain lighting condition is present
and a certain quality of mirror is
what's the lighting condition because
i'm gonna get my
[ __ ] flashlight and do the lighting
conditions right you're gonna have to go
to wiki how to find figure all the rest
of that out that's all i know because if
that was me i would have broke that
glass and been like
[ __ ] i just vandalized this bath
you come out with a bleeding face cause
i'm all like no
you [ __ ] pervert crack and i'm like
oh [ __ ] i just broke a window i'm sorry
can i can i pay for your damages no i'm
still doing it i'm gonna say
listen you this is suspicious it's your
fault right
flashy favorite what that's fair that's
fair that's fair
you can't break property just blame them
for being suspicious i mean obviously
i'll still
buy the replacement but i'm gonna say
you can't put it there you can't [ __ ]
put it there no like if there was like
let's say this was like a
a camera themed acai bowl shop
and there were like cameras prop cameras
in the bathroom
i would break that [ __ ] be like [ __ ] no
it looked like a real one yeah man
yeah so it's fine it's fine listen
it's your fault going into this [ __ ]
challenge i like to be watched
i like to be watched that's so funny you
go to a pervert themed
lounge and you're like why there's so
many perverts we pitched the new uh
franchise i'm out
camera themed acai camera thing
coffee shop uh
in the bathroom everyone has to take a
[ __ ] there's no cameras anywhere but the
bathroom
i actually just had coffee yesterday for
the first time since march how fast did
you take a [ __ ] it went right through
why did you make that like a little
thing where you're like no more caffeine
no because i only really drink coffee
when i'm out in the world slash working
or whatever so it was like pandemic so i
had no reason to drink coffee oh you
don't just wake up and say give me a cup
of coffee honey didn't me
oh okay natural meat i don't know that
and it was also the cafe so that
so very strong that's the strongest dude
that's me
that you every day every day every day
drinking
every day i want to but
every day i try to are you the vitamin i
just spoke it vietnam i just spoke here
oh what'd you say i said really you
drink caffeine today every day wait
that was that i said he didn't speak
venus that's not like you did not just
speak
it hey jump in the comments if you guys
are vietnamese you already know the
truth
i said that every day i tried to do it
they'll be in the comments we came for
you right now i didn't hear the actual
vietnamese that's why
i was like i thought it was an action
believe me i had your back
i i i only heard the cat face of that
part at the end
that's okay guys did you did you finally
catch that [ __ ] fly
it's a baby flight oh i feel bad
there's a mama fly for sure mama fly's
on the microphone y'all
oh it is yeah it's been there for a
while watching you kill it's baby
it's claudia's revenge all right it's
gonna go
yeah i'm such a [ __ ] [ __ ] where
should i put the flying next to mama
to say goodbye no mama flies on top of
the mic doing some asmr right now
he's literally staring right at you oh
my god this is really [ __ ] up this is
really [ __ ] up
so i'm going to put it next to the flood
i mean listen can you take a picture of
the moment
look they could see you with my phone
reflection kind of a little bit
the editors can edit this in a mama fly
and then and then take pictures of this
too just for fun
just for fun i'm sorry mama fly i'm very
[Music]
sorry
[Music]
you